okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p here
is a guy who is very upset i guess about
Virgina i i genuinely don't even know
what they're talking about take a listen
this is the type of hate by the way we
get every day hey purplish are you doing
reckless you know what your friends at
it's proof speech TV that little uh
you only you don't even have a hair on
your balls you don't have balls you got
walls vagina you know clitoris you're an
idiot
all right thought that was more i think
he stays on the phone for a while like
the voicemail is actually still going
okay and there he hung up all right no
response needed but this is a
get-out-the-vote reminder you're not
going to convince that guy to vote for a
democrat you're not going to convince
many of these people to consider
something other than trump so once again
just get out the vote there's tens of
millions of people who didn't vote last
time and who might not vote this time
who already agree with us just tell them
that they should go and vote because it
matters because people like this talking
about you know Proclus version a--'s and
balls we're not going to convince them
that that's very very clear on today's
bonus show we will talk about CNN's
Chris Cuomo in a video threatening a man
who called him Fredo and actually
equating the term Fredo to the n-word
was it a setup CNN is standing behind
him I have some thoughts we will also
talk about a company stirring debate
trying to trademark the concept of Taco
Tuesday is Taco Tuesday so ubiquitous
that it really should be beyond into our
intellectual property protections the
likes of which this company is trying to
get we will discuss that we will also
talk about really strange things going
on with this entire storm area51
event that is being planned and promoted
all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show two ways to get
instant access to the bonus show become
a member at wwe.com or become a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
I'll speak to you that